bonjour je suis Pascal chapon bienvenue
à Élancourt nous sommes sur le centre de
recherche et technologies d'aliexis sur
50 années je suis directeur de ce site
et aujourd'hui je vous présentais la
recherche et le développement que l'on
effectue dans le domaine de la gestion
des fluides et en particulier la gestion
de l'eau
[Musique]
nous sommes arrivés ici il y a un an en
2022 au départ nous sommes arrivés avec
30 chercheurs aujourd'hui nous sommes 60
personnes sur ce centre de recherche et
nous continuons à grandir avec un
nouveau bâtiment qui va être mise en
service à la fin de l'année
tout d'abord les matières en plastique
nous utilisons beaucoup de matières
places et une expertise sur les matières
plastiques des expertises mécaniques
chimiques pour développer nos produits
nos produits sont des produits dans le
transport des fluides et en particulier
le transport des fluides dans vos
maisons les canalisations mais aussi
dans les villes telles que les
infrastructures ou dans l'industrie nous
avons également des produits dans le
domaine agricole émine tu noter notre
responsable simulation peut tout nous
expliquer ce que tu es en train de faire
l'assimilation ça nous permet de réduire
le temps au lieu de faire 300 prototypes
on fait 300 simulations finalement en
deux trois produits ça nous permet de
réduire le coût accélérer l'innovation
et d'avoir moins de impacts sur
l'environnement
[Musique]
ici à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines nous
avons 12 nationalités pourquoi 51
Yvelines tout simplement parce que nous
avons la proximité de la région
parisienne mais aussi la proximité des
gares la proximité des aéroports ça nous
permet de recevoir nos clients à
l'international et nos partenaires à
l'international sur ce site en région
parisienne nous pouvons collaborer soit
avec des entreprises en recherche et
développement mais aussi avec des
centres de recherche sur le plateau de
Paris Saclay des centres universitaires
connus au niveau mondial puisque le
centre de Paris Saclay représente 70 000
chercheurs et le troisième pôle
industriellement nous allons maintenant
vous présenter les laboratoires de
aliexis R&D
[Musique]
ça veut dire les bactéries qui se
développent dans les réseaux d'eau et on
essaye justement de chercher des
solutions pour améliorer la qualité
microbiologique de l'eau ça me plaît
beaucoup d'être ici aussi parce que du
coup je suis à côté de Paris en même
temps que j'ai beaucoup de nature et
vraiment ça mais ça me permet de me
développer avec un grand contrat de
recherche
[Musique]
salut Vincent salut Pascal dis-moi sur
quoi tu travailles aujourd'hui là
actuellement je suis en train de
vérifier la processabilité donc la mise
en forme d'un nouveau PVC qui est un PVC
avec un impact environnemental plus
faible même vérifie que on peut bien le
mettre en forme pour pouvoir l'utiliser
dans nos futurs applications chez
Aliexpress moi ça fait 5 mois que je
suis Alexis et j'ai décidé de déménager
à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines parce que le
cadre me plaît tout simplement et parce
que je pouvais je peux venir en vélo au
travail donc ça permet de respecter mes
convictions écologiques et aussi de
faire du sport
ici nous allons être dans un mode
beaucoup plus open innovation en
travaillant avec des universités des
startups des centres de recherche privé
à côté de grandes sociétés comme Thales
ou Airbus ça donne de la visibilité et
aujourd'hui depuis que nous sommes
installés ici nous arrivons facilement à
attirer des talents pour des
publications de poste nous avons
régulièrement plus de 400 CD par poste
publié et ça c'est vraiment un avantage
d'être sur cette zone industrielle en
fait
[Musique]